auf dem flughafen der irischen
hauptstadt dublin ging am donnerstag
nicht viel heftiger schneefall und
starke winde sorgten für flugausfälle
und verspätungen
die sichtverhältnisse waren schlecht die
kaltfront aus dem osten sorgt in
großbritannien und irland für das
schlimmste winterwetter seit 1991 schnee
und kalte temperaturen auch in venedig
für eine fahrt mit der gondel war es am
donnerstag viel zu kalt nach aussage des
wetterdienstes soll es hier auch die
nächsten tage kalt und ungemütlich
bleiben noch mehr schnee und kälte gibt
es in osteuropa
dort gibt es in weiten teilen
temperaturen von mehr als minus 25 grad
in europa ist es damit zurzeit kälter
als in grönland holen und anderswo kamen
mehrere menschen wegen der kälte ums
leben doch auch die japaner leiden unter
dem kalten winterwetter bei einem
schweren schneesturm auf der insel
hokkaido im norden des landes kam
mindestens ein mensch ums leben flüge
wurden gestrichen züge fielen aus auf
vielen straßen war kein durchkommen
wohl dem dagegen der den schnee zu
nutzen weiß und wie dieser mann im
englischen norwich neue
einsatzmöglichkeiten für sein snowboard
findet